I'm Laura Ingram and this is the Ingram
angle thank you for being with us
tonight all right two stories today
about two great American cities on
opposite sides of the country should be
a major Awakening for all of us they
reveal important truths about how
America is faring as we're about to
commemorate our nation's Independence on
July 4th and while politicians in both
parties try to spin we need the truth
now more than ever
now if you've been in LA in the past few
years you're not going to be surprised
by this but homelessness grew a
staggering 10 percent in the city last
year and nine percent in L.A County my
office staff is afraid and it's so sad
for the people that are homeless and
it's a tragedy for the community when I
went outside there were just like
families walking around people walking
their dogs it was completely quiet and
safe and boring in a good way
and now I'm afraid to go out without my
pepper spray horrific and in the Big
Apple things are off the charts bad with
City shelters busting at the seams
filled with illegals now it's so bad
that earlier this month mayor Eric Adams
Even floated the idea of housing the
would-be asylees into private homes
that's a bad idea because you don't know
nothing about those people what he's
doing
is not good for the city he's destroying
the city I wouldn't want some stranger
illegal or not illegal just a stranger
in general so you're saying that if this
is going to take it I absolutely would
not
now it would be a real mistake for us
who don't live in either place to just
wave these stories off and I know it's
kind of a tendency oh no it doesn't
matter to me
but instead let's use the information
that I just gave you to win in 2024 and
begin restoring America
at La County's last count 75 518 people
were living in interim housing or a tent
a car a van an RV or makeshift shelter
and that was in LA County compared with
69 144 the previous year
and check this out since 2015 that
figure has risen an inconceivable 70 in
the county and 80 percent in the city of
Los Angeles
so this is insane so now why is this
happening oh is it Trump's fault
well who runs La who runs California
those are the questions we have to ask
we know who they are they're Democrats
and they like to tax regulate and spend
uh the city and the state into Oblivion
and look they wanted that they voted for
it and they got it and the official
who's in charge of the agency dealing
with homelessness said the following in
the LA Times the reasons for the spike
in homelessness are not fully known but
then pointed to economics as the
underlying cause you think but then she
noted a study by U.S UC San Francisco
that found that among people who had
leases before becoming homeless a
decrease in income was the most common
reason for losing their housing well
bidenomics strikes again
not a lot of trickle down from my
parents kitchen table when I was growing
up so we're changing we decided to
replace this Theory with what the Press
is now called by Dynamics I don't know
what the hell that is
it's working
oh sure Joe
now let's get you back to bed now okay
now what's obvious is that bidenomics
plus an open border equals a total
nightmare for Americans who want to be
independent but are overwhelmed by
inflation and every other malady that
the Democrats policies are causing
the middle class has been left behind
when you go to the grocery store you do
not see anything that's decreased is
your grocery bill higher absolutely
yeah inflation through the roof do you
think the country's on the right track
or the wrong track totally the wrong
track would you say you're better or
worse off since he took office yeah much
worse off worse off than we've ever been
now I know what you're thinking when
will New York in California vote to save
themselves when is it going to happen
now all Democrats can do in response is
somehow blame Republican Governors like
DeSantis or you know Abbott in Texas or
proposed tax hikes or try to change the
subject altogether
rather than urge new and sane approaches
to fix the economy and the Border they
try to hold on to Power by stoking more
Division and dangling freebies now
they're doing the same thing with
reparations just yesterday the
California reparations task force
released its final report and provided
115 recommendations on how black
residents should be compensated
it could include cash payments it can
include free tuition to our UCS and CSUS
it can be as first time home buyer
assistance down payment interest-free
loans state tax relief free health care
on and on and on we can do this
[Applause]
the key here is that they have yet to
put a dollar figure on the reparations
payments themselves
now this isn't that kind of pivotal
especially when California has a 32
billion dollar budget deficit like if
they really wanted to do reparations
they'd pass a bill they'd raise taxes on
the rich donors of of the Democrats and
then start sending out the checks
but the angle does not think they're
ever ever going to do that instead they
want to keep doing studies and you know
launch commissions and all a bunch of
news reports and polls and all of those
sorts of things to make people think
that any day now the money's coming
we have a debt that needs to be paid it
needs to be paid our time has come and
this reparations will be making rights
the many centuries are wrong reparations
about repair to me I qualify I would
like to see you guys get give out
letters of credit where we can buy
property we can do things instead of
waiting I'm 78 years old I don't want to
wait two or three years
well I hate to tell him this but
unlikely that that money is ever going
to come because it's all a lie and it's
all another cynical ploy to trap people
into thinking there's some magic pot of
money out there and that the government
is just going to take care of all of you
forever
and all of that turns and devotes the
Democrats hope for themselves
now today brought us another example of
the left's power play Biden's fraudulent
promise to pay off student loans
now it's a scheme with one purpose again
buying off the votes this time of young
people why did you give millions of
borrowers false hope you've dated
doubted your own authority here in the
past I didn't give any false hope what I
did I thought was appropriate and was
able to be done and would get done I
didn't give bars also but the
Republicans snatched away the hope that
it was they were given and it's real
real hope now they could have eliminated
student loans through legislation or at
least tried to do that but they didn't
instead they pretended to do something
that never had a chance of surviving
school Court scrutiny so if you're
someone who voted for the Democrats
because you thought your student loans
were going to be forgiven or if you
voted for Democrats because you thought
that you're going to get a big pile of
money in the form of reparations
well I'm here to tell you that you were
played for a fool the left knew exactly
what they were doing they knew that this
wasn't going to you know in any way be
upheld by the court and they don't have
any intention of writing checks to
anyone for reparations hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else